good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight finally a happy story
for once outbursts of irrepressible Joy
erupted throughout the exclusive Island
community of Martha's Vineyard
Massachusetts last night
for hundreds of years Martha's Vineyard
had suffered from the soul-crushing
effects of its own whiteness Island
residents understood there was only one
cure they badly needed diversity in fact
they often said so but despite their
very best efforts over many years
diversity never came to Martha's
Vineyard it was tragic imagine an 18th
century British frigate adrift on the
high seas with no limes
Sailors slowly going mad convulsing
dying excruciating deaths from scurvy
that was Martha's Vineyard except it
wasn't lime juice they lacked they had
plenty of that because you can't make a
gin and tonic without it what Martha's
Vineyard lacked was diversity which is
to say strength Martha's Vineyard was a
very weak place as of yesterday morning
that Island was 89 percent white
monochromatic and utterly homogeneous
nearly everybody there was a rich
Democrat 80 percent voted for Joe Biden
the median home price was over a million
dollars
and then in a single blessed moment
everything changed relief arrived for an
unlikely Source Governor Ron DeSantis of
Florida having made his own state of
paradise decided to help other states
desperately in need so yesterday
DeSantis sent 50 illegal aliens most of
them from Venezuela to the Martha's
Vineyard Airport they traveled from San
Antonio to the Florida Panhandle and
finally to their new home on Martha's
Vineyard
CBS Boston reports that after landing
the group wandered about three and a
half miles from the airport into town
thereby instantly improving it you can
imagine the unrestrained Jubilation on
Martha's Vineyard tonight
long-suffering Islanders finally rescued
from their own oppressive whiteness in
fact let's go there now to check in on
the celebrations
well that's not expected obviously
there's been a mistake nor our producers
are telling us there are no technical
problems that is in fact a live shot
from Martha's Vineyard Massachusetts
right now
but where were the Weeping joyful crowds
where was the champagne and the ticker
tape we expected Times Square and VJ Day
what we got was a cemetery at midnight
what
but maybe it's not so confusing maybe
things aren't as they seem our first
clue is Barack Obama
Barack Obama is a part-time resident of
Martha's Vineyard Obama's also of course
as you know the country's greatest
proponent of diversity for years Obama
earnestly told us that immigrants were
better than Americans they were holy
they make our Country Strong
America is and always has been a nation
of immigrants
throughout our history immigrants have
come to our Shores and wave after wave
from every corner of the globe
every one of us unless we're Native
American has an ancestor who was born
somewhere else that's what it makes
America special that's what makes us
strong
the basic idea of welcoming immigrants
to our Shores is Central to our way of
life it is in our DNA
basically the whole presidency right
there for eight years Obama hectoring us
about diversity but he didn't just talk
about it he spent his two years in
office making certain that places like
Des Moines Iowa and Portland Maine
became much less white than they
previously had been because as he so
often told us whiteness is bad it's a
disease
so we recall being a little confused
when we read that Barack Obama had spent
12 million dollars to buy an eight
bathroom oceanfront property on Martha's
Vineyard which is one of the whitest
places on Earth really Martha's Vineyard
Why Not Baltimore or Gary Indiana is
there really no real estate left in
Detroit for the Obama family compound
there's got to be
what's going on here we didn't know
and then in 2019 Michelle Obama
explained it to us listen to this
we grew up in the period as I write
called white flight that has families
like ours upstanding families like ours
you know who were doing everything we
were supposed to do and better as we
moved in uh white folks moved out
because they were afraid of what our
families represented and I always
stopped there when I talk about this out
out in the world because you know I want
to remind white folks that
y'all were running running from us and
you're still running
because we're no different than the
Immigrant families that are moving in
the families in Pilsen the the families
that are coming from other places to try
to do better and so yeah I felt I feel a
sense of Injustice
so there she was reminding white folks
who badly needed reminding that the
Obamas are quote no different from the
Immigrant families moving in because
white people hate them too they're still
running as she just said so that
explained it to us the Obamas were in
fact despised immigrants so when they
moved to a 12 million dollar Seaside
Compound on Martha's Vineyard the point
is not to live in luxury with other rich
people no obviously the point is to
diversify Martha's Vineyard to strike a
blow for justice it made sense to us and
we felt better
but then last night happened and we
started to rethink our assumptions about
the Obamas about a lot of things
because a plane load of Highly diverse
immigrants arrived on Martha's Vineyard
to join the Obamas but the Obamas didn't
welcome them
there was not a word from Barack or
Michelle Obama Barack wasn't waiting at
the airport to greet the diversifiers
with flowers he didn't issue a statement
of congratulations he didn't invite a
single Venezuelan to his home
how come
could it be that Barack Obama isn't
really actually in real life in favor of
diversity at all could it be that Barack
Obama strongly prefers blonde Soul cycle
moms in Lululemon to sweaty third world
campesinos and dirty work pants could it
be we can't say
but we can tell you that if you want to
find out what people really think go
ahead and ignore what they say and watch
how they live
and by that measure the one that matters
Barack Michelle Obama are every bit as
bigoted as any board member at any
restricted Country Club in the Deep
South assuming those still exist those
people they're not dating mud daughter I
can tell you that
so in other words we learned this week
that Barack Obama really is a racist and
not in the way you've always assumed
Obama May hate white people he certainly
seems to but he also demands to live
around them and only them
but the Obama is to be fair are not
alone in this his friends at the news
networks in Washington New York and Los
Angeles feel exactly the same way
because they're exactly the same sort of
people
CNN for example spent the day
interviewing people connected in some
way to Martha's Vineyard turns out that
precisely none of them were excited
about the plane load of Venezuelans one
of them the state repped for the island
even blamed this show for the sudden
blessed surge in diversity watch this
Rhonda Santos and Republicans might want
to play political games with people's
lives I believe that's incredibly
inhumane to be using Women and Children
and Families as a political Pawn that
you can then not talk about on Tucker
Carlson and pretend to be tough on
immigration
wow so see if you can follow the
argument here when petting this illegal
aliens show up in Brownsville Texas one
of the poorest cities in the United
States they are noble Strivers they're
looking for a better life in this
country and we applaud them good luck in
Brownsville newly arrived immigrants
but when these very same people jump
them out and get a free flight to
Martha's Vineyard it's something else
entirely it is as the State Rep just
told you quote playing political games
with people's lives because it's
dangerous these immigrants could wander
into a clambake by accident or Worse
much worse
earlier today CNN anchored John Berman
who's got fired by the way this morning
this morning John Berman interviewed
noted filmmaker Ken Burns
Burns is famous but sad exactly the kind
of middle-aged Prestige Hound who spends
an awful lot of time looming around
Martha's Vineyard looking for other
famous people Burns has a new film out
that blames the United States of all
countries on Earth for the Holocaust now
that the World War II generation has
passed Ken Burns can do that there's no
chance angry veterans will show up at
his house and beat him with their canes
for besmirching the memory of their
closest friends who died in their early
20s fighting the Nazis
so Ken's Burns can say whatever he wants
if any will believe him
so this morning Burns played the role of
Holocaust expert on CNN and you know
what Ken Burns has discovered
Ken Burns has discovered that Ron
DeSantis sending illegal aliens to
Martha's Vineyard is pretty much exactly
what Hitler did pretty much exactly
watch this
all of your documentaries are about
history yeah but all of them also make
you think about where we are exactly and
we woke up to the news this morning that
Governor Ron DeSantis of Florida sent
two plane loads of migrants uh to
Martha's Vineyard off the coast of
Massachusetts include kids and whatnot
and I'm not saying this is not a one for
one this is not a parallel here in any
way but it does address some of the same
themes this is the coming straight out
of the authoritarian Playbook this is
what's so uh disturbing about DeSantis
is to use human beings to weaponize
human beings for a political purpose
oh you hear that ladies and gentlemen
it's literally literally just like the
Holocaust Edgar town is dacao Oak Bluff
says Treblinka the horrors this is
genocide
and it may be but of course everything
is relative Martha's Vineyard may be a
modern day death camp but compared to
where illegal aliens usually go it
doesn't look that bad
let's compare just for fun on your
screen you will see images recently shot
in America's border towns which are now
completely overrun under Joe Biden's
immigration policy you will notice if
you look carefully chaos violence and
filth okay now we will take you to
Martha's Vineyard it's hellish perhaps
but in a very different way
families eating together on balconies
overlooking the water women doing their
shopping in a quaint little town on
bicycles couples strolling along the
boardwalk sailboats
doesn't look that bad ah but that's
exactly the problem the media told us
today Martha's Vineyard may seem like
one of the richest places on the planet
but somehow somehow there aren't enough
Social Services there it's bereft of
Social Services unlike Brownsville
as CBS News put it quote Martha's
Vineyard is not an urban metropolitan
area with a robust Social Services
infrastructure there's no justice
department Immigration Court where the
migrants can attend Asylum hearings
there's no ice field office where
migrants can check in
now
but you see Martha's Vineyard is in
quote an urban area with a quote robust
Social Services infrastructure that
other people get to deal with
and honestly that's true and it's kind
of the whole idea that's why DeSantis
sent the illegal aliens to Martha's
Vineyard
people who make and advocate for certain
policies should at some point have to
live with those policies
but until now they haven't had to Bill
Gates goes to Martha's Vineyard so does
Oprah James Taylor Spike Lee Amy Schumer
and many more and all of them everyone
is a much better person than you are
because they support diversity and now
for the first time they're going to have
some diversity but it's just the
beginning Martha's video will lead many
many more illegal aliens tens of
thousands more until the island is no
longer majority White only then can it
be a good place yet at the same time the
people who currently go to Martha's
Vineyard are going to have to keep going
there they can't run away to somewhere
else that would be immoral it would be
as Michelle Obama has told us white
flight
now massive demographic change will
obviously make Martha's Vineyard a very
different sort of place but that's okay
change is good anyone who fears change
is racist we know that for sure because
they've told us that for years
so where you may ask will all these new
people live on such a small island
simple first they can occupy Barack
Obama's compound there is no reason
Obama needs that much space nobody needs
that much space you could probably fit a
dozen immigrant families in Barack
Obama's pool house and another five or
six in the pantry keep going build a
soccer field on the lawn an outdoor goat
barbecue by the back door and bingo
you've got affordable housing but it
won't be enough
The Vineyard is going to need to
construct Shanty towns for all these new
people but we can't call them Shanty
towns obviously that's demeaning
so we're going to call them townships
after Obama's favorite country and then
we're going to give them dignified names
that suggest some kind of victory over
adversity Mandela
Cesar chavezville Kamala apopolis
now each side each one will put a plaque
with that famous Emma Lazarus poem just
so that everybody knows that these are
not ordinary favelas these are moral
victories as the signs say in Martha's
Vineyard to this day no human is illegal
Love Is Love that's just science
but speaking of science what will the
environmental impact of all this new
development be that's a massive concern
on Martha's vinegar and for good reason
but in this case it's not a concern none
of these new townships will have running
water or electricity so by definition
they will be carbon neutral it'll be
part of the Green Revolution
local law enforcement Services won't be
strained either because they won't be
needed none of these new arrivals will
be bound by local laws why would they be
they ignored federal law to get here
there's no reason that they should have
to observe The Vineyards ordinances
against say drunk driving or defecating
in public
and just in case there are still
vineyarders who think they have the
right to protect what they own think
again people we refer you to the case of
the fascist McCloskey family in St Louis
who once tried that tried to defend
what's theirs and they got indicted for
it so that's not allowed
but we can't fully trust you somebody's
gonna have to go door to door to make
sure that not one person on Martha's
Vineyard keeps a gun at home because
self-defense can be tempting even for
Democratic voters
there's a lot of change for the vineyard
and they're getting to start work soon
the summer season begins on Memorial Day
so when Amy Schumer shows up to her
place in June she better be ready to
find an illegal alien family using her
bath towels yes she will and let's hope
she doesn't complain about it because as
Joe Biden often reminds us illegal
immigration is a gift
guess what they're the reason why the
legal as well as undocumented the reason
why our society is functioning the
reason why our economy is growing we
don't talk about that we stand up and
act like it's a burden it is not a
burden it's a gift
hear that hear that illegal immigration
is not a burden it's a gift Dumbo so
Martha's Vineyard received an enormous
gift last night think of it like a
Perpetual Christmas but noisier
and you can't beat the timing as Korean
Jean-Pierre just reminded us today at
the White House it's Hispanic Heritage
Month perfect so roll with it Martha's
Vineyard
things are about to change a lot for you
but that's okay radical destructive
change is the essence of anti-racism and
as you've told us so many times you
support anti-racism
lest we need to remind you and in any
case pretty soon you'll have no memory
of the way things were before
Martha's Vineyard will feel and look
just like El Paso and that will all seem
normal to you what's El Paso like you
wonder haven't been there lately okay
well here's some recent pictures
I want to show you an exact look of what
we're seeing out here we're right next
to the Greyhound bus station where as
we've been telling you for days now
migrants mostly a large group of
Venezuelans have been using this area as
a temporary camp and a home now take a
look at this video from earlier this
morning and overnight where you can see
migrants have setups leaving
Arrangements on cardboard and mattresses
in this same spot here outside the bus
station d'agostito and other City leader
said their number one priority is to
avoid people on the streets but since
CBP has been so overwhelmed with the
large numbers coming in they have been
forced to release as such as more and
more people have been on the streets in
recent days sanitation and cleanliness
have become a concern out here we're not
seeing any porta potties or temporary
toilets showers or sinks and as you can
imagine the smell is beginning to add up
oh wow look El Paso is Venezuelans too
and that's why tonight it's redolent of
diversity brimming with the gift of
illegal immigration that'll be Edgartown
Massachusetts soon but we can't stop
there why would we if we're really going
to make Martha's Vineyard look like the
world the people who vacation on
Martha's Vineyard have you created for
the rest of us
we're going to need to import graffiti
artists and armed robbers and Subway
rapists in the drug addicted homeless
Community many many of those and they're
tents why should they be living outside
your house when they can be camped on
Barack Obama's 12 million dollar lawn
that seems fair why isn't it fair
well unfortunately don't expect Obama to
see it the same way he is a racist as
we've established and so apparently are
his fellow liberals they are outraged by
the idea of illegal aliens near their
island vacation homes
but for long they'll be tweeting in
solidarity with The Vineyards White
Community hashtag I stand with Martha's
Vineyard Little Island emojis in their
bios hilarious that could actually
happen by the way because in the end
liberals really do stand with Martha's
Vineyard against everyone else
and honestly on some level we can kind
of understand why if we're being honest
we don't want to see Martha's Vineyard
trashed we're Americans and Martha's
Vineyard is a beautiful place it's a sin
to destroy beautiful things always
unfortunately and this really is the
point
Martha's Vineyard is one of a dwindling
number of beautiful places left in our
country Martha's Vineyard is what most
of America once was not all that long
ago
small socially cohesive orderly safe
with traditional human-centered
architecture and big stretches of nature
unspoiled by industrial wind farms and
dollar stores
the people who live in Martha's Vineyard
now didn't build any of that the people
who did build it are long gone along
with the attitudes and values that made
it possible
the people who live there now just came
for the Nostalgia and all that's left
really are the buildings and the beaches
but still you'd hate to see them wrecked
on the other hand at this point we may
have no choice
no sane country would allow millions of
foreign Nationals to walk across its
borders illegally and then immediately
give them government benefits in
exchange for mocking a rule of law no
one would ever do that it is suicide
over time it will destroy the United
States everyone can see that no matter
what they say
but the people with vacation on Martha's
Vineyard don't care they are making this
possible they support it they vote for
it they fund it and they can do all of
that because they are so insulated from
the effects of Joe Biden's lunatic
immigration policies that none of it
matters to them
the country collapses big deal they live
on an island
but to the rest of us it is a big deal
this is our country we were born here we
plan to die here we have nowhere else to
go and we don't want to live in a slum
maybe Martha's Vineyard will finally
understand subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight